all right it's been a super fun
sometimes frightening hour but let's
close out with some Halloween Joy this
is what I'm
liking all right so dressing up and
going door to door for candy is a
childhood ride of Passage a Houston high
schooler wants to make sure that every
kid gets that opportunity no matter
their financial means so he created
yelloween which I love he distributes
brand new costumes to Kids in Need in
his community and we have him on the
line right now along with his mama say
hi to BJ and Tracy watching on box 6
everybody what's up y'all hi hi oh my
God I love this is the coolest thing
ever because by the way I was one of
those kids that totally could have used
money for costume so how did this start
uh it started back uh three years ago
when we started the pandemic we saw that
there was a lot of people who lost their
jobs and that kids weren't able to get
costumes so I just love Halloween I
cannot go without it and so we really
wanted to spread that and so we became
Yow which is Halloween for all y'all I
love it Mama great job what a beautiful
young man your heart so how how many
costumes do you all do a year so since
our first year in 2021 we've distributed
over 750 costumes um the way it works is
we have partner organizations that
support transitional housing or domestic
violence abuse victims and they give us
a list of the kids in their programs
with their gender and their age and if
they want to be a princess or a
superhero and we match them up with
costumes that have been donated or that
BJ has raised money to buy for his
fundraising I am so incredibly proud of
BJ my kids have never wanted for
anything and he's helping these parents
that are having tough Economic Times
provide a little bit of normality and
some joy to these kids on our favorite
holiday Halloween absolutely it's
escapism every kid you know that should
get that Joy of like the theme of
dressing up whatever you being creative
there's so much into it and my my kids
love it specifically my son uh thank you
so much BJ for just having such a great
heart and Tracy thank you so much for
raising such a great young man I'm
liking your post right now right thank
you so much Kelly yeah and that's not
all guys our season long partner pilot
pin makers of friction that go to
erasable pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
recognize that you're giving kids in
your community the gift of a simple
pleasure so they're giving you ,000 to
get started on your efforts for next
year's
costume thank you guys so much making
Texas crb and thank you to all our
guests out Kyle Richards Keith Morrison
DC youngfly RI K Richard and Samar y'all
have a great Halloween it it's not
trying to change
[Applause]
[Music]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home